Keith and I are chefs but not Korea
right gene is Korean but not a chef
so how is that gonna do oh I think there
is a growing interest in Korean cuisine
because the popular culture introduced
it in such a delicious manner what do
you do
I am here sir oh I am the Korean mom
you're the Korean mom we've always
wanted to have really family members
eating around the table that's when many
conflicts emerge Japan met had mom so
Eugene's gonna be my mom I'm not your
mom so I got mom here tell me how your
mom consumption of food is not just
something that your body needs but it's
something that also your emotion needs
okay today we're going to make the
cookie dick pokey the book is a number
one strip food in Korea have you never
had luck before this is duck I had duck
at a flower the bird duck it's a rice
cake that's different kind of cake it
tastes like string cheese that rolled
under the couch so mom what's the first
day your mom first we need to do is to
make an Toby block then she'll be
brought
are you freaked out by little fish I'm
not freaked out by it but the holding
around a lot yeah there you go
dad yeah you want to get your job sure I
didn't realize I had a job
si si 40 and then one pick up a fish
water one more cup official next thing
we need to do is go cheetah that smells
good don't you John what you got you
heard of it I've seen it right now and
it is very red but I get how much I put
on this is there real spicy no more if I
drank that whole thing would I be in the
hospital I got all their mouths are you
me hard oh my god amazing
three tablespoons Oh back Jim defeating
daddy you want to have extra spicy kick
no sure what you got it I don't trust
you the clear and whole thing Eugene
it's red that's a spicy Tuesday this is
one tablespoon soy sauce go get it bro
no why do you have to try sugar mmm this
looks red it's all about composite yeah
Wow
like I said balance at the same time his
mom I put my duck in there you can put
your duck in there call the fingers in
the bot fingers in their pot I'm
splashing splashing everywhere yeah
don't don't splash this is called a Mook
and it's fishy cake and it's like a
flattened fried fish cake of sorts if
you cut it diagonally yeah it would be
pretty Oh Oh go for it little triangles
is that impressive
I love triangle to chop the rest of this
up okay oh no throw it no you're not
throwing the fish cake do you like a fun
thing throw I love cabbage what'd I do
with that chop it up nice knife skills
keep things so can we put in the cabbage
yet sure wait go for it Ned let's grab a
fistful so once you've got everything
boiled in for a second then you add
these fish cakes now we just let this
simmer for a while yeah we're a great
team
there was no flaws in our system we
worked really well together
no fish cakes were lost sesame oil is a
very important Oh can I taste some it's
good it tastes like oil oh my god I feel
is just probably good for the skin - all
right oh no no no no they say it's good
for the skin man you said that then Oh
mom dad let me scam you at the table you
know okay okay so it's now time to put
our final ingredient oh we can all do it
together yeah
Oh
it was all one that was a group not a
part of this family my time for tasting
okay oh my goodness it's good busy
Pisces
oh it's so well-balanced we're all
having a Korean good time you got keep
yeah I'm good probably mom what's our
next dish so we're about to cook one of
my favorite childhood Korean dishes
creating focus very well seasoned it's
very easy to make it only takes three
ingredients inside because we're making
mini gimbap we're gonna cut this in half
what's over there you did oh my gosh to
my core I just got chilled there's no
way my mom says ug and you get the rice
scooper she were just good you have to
season this really well for keep up to
taste get we're ready to roll lift the
the end that's closer to you and just
roll it there's no really magic to it
the other try guys have to do this on
their own and their can complain to see
who can make the best mini kimbap
I think it's will taste the best I think
Ned's will look the best Ned all the way
what are you sawing I think that gonna
be the one that's just gonna be an
explosion of rice and stuff okay so we
each have two minutes to make kimbap if
you've been watching this video you
probably expect me to do horribly on
this I'm gonna try and prove you wrong
first rice already seasoned I've got a
nice bed of rice you don't need that
much rice take your time patience is
important when cooking how many of these
two did she put in two I hope it was -
he was wrong you only need one of these
things I rolled things in college so I
have prior knowledge on how to do this
think I might have put too much rice in
here then you roll it your duns it's not
that hard
oh no I'm losing time so hard to recover
once you [ __ ] it up lube this up
sprinkle bingo
this is real slippery let's make another
I'm not feeding my only one I made
Eugene Eugene
yes so now we're gonna judge the other
try guys
kimbap to see which one is the best this
one it's not the best it's like a very
like ping-pong person in a very small
shirt what about the sesame on each one
I think this was a little bit over them
looks like there's a lot of seen it but
the extra on the sides here is very
Korean actually right it's very Korean
probably just to be sure which one
tastes good right so your official
decision is tomato one number two
my name is Keith fan I know how to cook
y'all who is second best this one yeah
I'm the second best Korean cook of all
time hey this carrot sticking out as a
feature not a bug huh
oh we creamed em we've all learned
something today thank you I love you too
Korean food is not that hard to make
it's very approachable select the dish
find a good recipe and try it
the more you practice the better you get